the way that we produce and consume
dairy today is nothing like it's been
for thousands of years
and has resulted in nutritionally
inferior foods
the cows are fed differently the milk is
treated differently and we even eat it
differently
the key to unlocking the potential of
this amazing resource lies in the past
hi i'm dr bill schindler food
archaeologist chef
and director of the eastern shore food
lab at washington college
consuming dairy as infants has been a
part of our diets for almost 200 million
years
since our earliest mammal ancestors
first appeared
in fact the very definition of mammals
refers to the presence of mammary glands
that we and other animals use to produce
the milk that feeds our young
milk is an incredible food designed to
nourish animals during one of the most
nutritionally important times in their
life
early development
as infants the milk we drink from our
mothers is completely alive and teeming
with beneficial bacteria
and interestingly enough it's already in
the process of fermenting by the time
that we drink it
if you've ever had a baby spit up on
your shoulder and it looked like cottage
cheese and smelled like provolone
that's because it is as infants we are
literally transforming milk into cheese
as we digest it
in fact when we ferment milk outside of
our bodies
using traditional techniques we are
actually replicating natural processes
that happen
inside of our bodies when we were young
when it hits our digestive tract
it combines with a number of different
enzymes such as lactase which helps
digest lactose
or lip paste which helps break down the
fat and even chymosin or tymosin-like
enzymes that help coagulate the milk
coagulating the milk turns it into a
thicker substance so that it remains
longer in our digestive tracts
this allows it to chemically and
physically break down more fully
so that more nutrients can be absorbed
and used by our bodies
when mammals get older and begin to eat
solid foods
many lose the ability to produce the
enzymes that they use
to digest the milk that's why so many
humans experience some level of lactose
intolerance as they get older
however our ancestors figured out how to
safely and effectively
obtain nutrition from the milk of other
animals even as adults
the archaeological record suggests that
we started consuming dairy from other
animals
somewhere between 8 and 10 000 years ago
back then
it's believed that very few traditional
groups would actually drink milk
instead they would ferment their dairy
into a number of different foods
including clabber kefir yogurt
butter and cheese when our ancestors did
this they relied upon naturally
occurring lactobacillus bacteria
to replicate the processes that took
place in their digestive tracts when
they were infants
this type of fermentation chemically and
physically transforms the dairy
and results in a number of different
health benefits these include
number one reducing or eliminating
lactose
which many adults can't digest two
increasing the probiotic content three
increasing acidity and creating a safe
environment that's hostile to pathogens
four pre-digesting the milk and making
it easier to metabolize
5. increasing the content of vitamins
such as b
and k2 and 6. it also improves the
milk's flavor
aroma and texture however traditional
dairy fermentation
is both a labor and time intensive
process
it is difficult to scale and impossible
to rush
while still creating the same quality
and nutritional benefits
[Music]
as populations in urban areas grew in
the 19th century
drastically increasing the demand for
milk many things about the way the milk
was produced
stored transported and even consumed
began to change
for example swill milk was created by
pairing distilleries with dairies
so that the leftover grains from the
distilling process could be used to feed
the cows
these cows were fed diets that were not
designed to eat
lived in crowded filthy conditions
became sick
and produced tainted milk to make it
taste and look better
all sorts of things were added to the
milk from molasses to animal brains
milk production distribution and
consumption
eventually got to the point that it was
making people sick and
killing them especially infants in order
to protect consumers
a relatively new invention
pasteurization
was used to kill off pathogens by
boiling the milk on the surface
pasteurization sounds like a good idea
especially when compared to transforming
an
entire industry and the way in which
most of the country
obtained prepared and consumed its milk
simply boiling the milk is much easier
more efficient and cheaper
but it's not that simple at the end of
the process it is degrading vitamins
and killing the probiotics and milk in
addition to pasteurization
we have adopted the practice of
homogenizing our milk
which prevents the fat from separating
and cream rising to the top
homogenization involves physically
forcing the cream through microscopic
holes in metal plates
causing the fat molecules to explode and
break apart
this results in smaller fat globules
that don't separate from the milk
homogenization serves no safety or
nutritional purpose whatsoever
the only thing that it does is relieves
us modern milk drinkers from having to
shake the gallon of milk in the morning
before we pour it on our cereal
the dairy aisle in our grocery stores
today contain hundreds of different
products
everything that is except for the milk
that our ancestors consumed
most of our milk today comes from huge
dairy farms then it's pasteurized and
separated into different parts
such as fat skim milk and milk solids
then the milk is artificially recombined
to meet minimum standards and maximize
profits
most modern fermented dairy products are
made from pasteurized milk
and require the addition of laboratory
created bacterial colonies to kick-start
the fermentation
almost all of these fermented offerings
have been adulterated
and contain unnatural additives
processed cheese
processed cheese food and processed
cheese products
do not deliver the same safety and
nutrition
that traditionally fermented cheese does
in fact
many of the cheeses in our grocery store
labeled mozzarella
are made using a shortcut method of
artificially introducing acid
and they never go through a fermentation
process at all this is not the same milk
that our ancestors consumed and we're
not consuming it in the same way
and those two things make all the
difference
we need to change things for our own
health the health of our animals
and the health of the planet there are a
number of different things that we can
do
we need to reconnect with our food and
take back control
by supporting small local dairy farmers
whenever possible
purchase minimally processed milk for
example
swap out homogenized milk for
non-homogenized cream-lined versions
if you're buying pasteurized milk select
pasteurized
over ultra pasteurized learn to ferment
your milk
and make it into a number of different
traditional products
such as kefir clabber yogurt
butter and cheese in your home kitchen
and if you don't do those things
yourself support the people that do
by purchasing from small local producers
that use high quality milk
and traditional methods it is impossible
to transform
any industry on a global scale overnight
but that's okay powerful change begins
with the decisions that we make
on how we feed our own families